you watch Joe Rogan I do but like just
the clips like it's a lot like it's like
a three-hour comment you just what you
do is you just download one and then on
a flight you just throw that [__] on
and then by the time you land it's over
I don't got that time bro you're sitting
on a plane I gotta do other [__] on the
plane what do you do on a plane that
like not that like I listen to like
various assortments of music and then
like I watch Like whatever's the best
movie and then I text people and then I
try to go to sleep and then I do [__]
like that like I can't I got too much
add to just sit down and just hear like
these two just two dudes just talking
here two dudes it's crazy just shooting
this [__] for three hours oh [__]